des lieux de vie serein pour retrouver
l'estimé de soi
c'est ce que propose l'association
entracte au jeune adolescent yvelinois
en décrochage scolaire installé au sein
de la maison de l'enfance de
mantes-la-jolie la structure propose un
accueil de jour durant cette semaine
tout au long de l'année scolaire
on travaille sur le développement
personnel à les amener à se connaître
mieux pour pouvoir se réintégrer on
travaille beaucoup aussi exactement sur
sur les rythmes les rythmes et de
sommeil première objectifs qu'on s'est
fixés d'essayer de les ramener dans un
rythme qui va leur permettre derrière
d'aller vers l'insertion
les jeunes sont adressés par les
services de protection de l'enfance
le département des yvelines a choisi de
financer entièrement ce dispositif
innovant
ça n'a aucun sens d'être comme nous
sommes un département particulièrement
performant dans les domaines économiques
dans les domaine écologique dans le
domaine urbain
dans tous les domaines à peu près de la
société et avoir des plaies sociales des
blessures social comme celle là le
programme gratuit pour les jeunes et
leurs familles inclut également du
théâtre et un séjour en corse
objectif générer de la confiance et
trouver sa place dans un groupe